[Musik] hallo zusammen wir machen heute Zitronen
Brownies die werden ultra saftig es ist ein sehr
einfaches Rezept also Anfänger geeignet ich
habe jetzt hier auch schon die Zutaten stehen
ihr findet alle ganz genau Mengenangaben
unten in der Infobox und ich starte direkt
ich habe jetzt hier Eier die schlage ich
in meine Schüssel ich nehme eigentlich
mal meine Hand meine Küchenmaschine wollte
euch das ganze mit dem Handrührgerät zeigen
weil das funktioniert auch ihr müsst auch nicht
großartig jetzt viel aufschlagen oder viel Luft
reinschlagen im Gegenteil Brownies in der eher
so faji und saftig genau zu den Eiern gebe ich
jetzt hier einmal noch Zucker und immer bei süßen
Rezepten was ich gerne dazu gebe ist eine gute
Prise Salz die unterstreicht noch mal den süßen
Geschmack so und das ganze dann so ungefähr eine
Minute aufschlagen so ein bisschen miteinander
verbinden lassen und dann geht's weiter [Musik]
so zerlassene Butter und Öl habe ich auch ganz
kurz mit eingerührt und jetzt geht es an die
Zitrone da könnt ihr jetzt wenn ihr merkt dass sie
ein bisschen fest ist einfach so ein bisschen auf
der Arbeitsfläche hin und her rollen dann bekommt
ihr so ein bisschen mehr Saft raus und ich finde
es auch mal wichtig zu erwähnen wie groß eine
Zitrone im Rezept ist wenn ihr zum Beispiel so
eine ganz kleine habt dann habt ihr weniger
Zitronengeschmack oder wenn sie riesengroß
ist das ist auf jeden Fall eine Bio Zitrone da
könnt ihr die Schale mit verwenden und das macht
im Geschmack auch noch mal richtig was aus falls
ihr keine Zitrone da habt es gibt bei Kaufland in
der Backabteilung auch Bio Zitronenschalen Abrieb
habe ich immer in der Schublade und das könntet
ihr dann auch verwenden so da gebe ich jetzt
einfach mit dieser feinen Reibe nur die gelbe
Schale rein wichtig leute bitte beachtet dass uns
ärgert ihr euch sagt das Rezept von Kiki schmeckt
gar nicht aber wenn ihr unter der gelben Schale
da kommt der die weiße Schale und die schmeckt
bitter und wenn ihr die dazu reibt dann ist zu
spät dann ist vorbei und dann schmeckt es total
bitter und ihr könnt es nicht mehr da hätten
wir aufpassen und vor allem eine feine Reibe
verwenden und keine grobe und habt ihr auch so
ein komisches Mundgefühl später wenn ihr da so
große Stücke drin habt und da gebe ich jetzt wie
gesagt auch noch den Saft dieser mittelgroßen
Zitrone mit rein und ganz zum Schluss noch mehl
und Backpulver das müsst ihr auch nicht sieben das
wird einfach eingerührt kurze bevor ihr mich hier
wäscht in den Kommentaren ich weiß bei Brownies
kommt kein Backpulver mit rein aber in dem Fall
machen wir das einfach für die Konsistenz ist
wir trotzdem eine Brownie Konsistenz aber
wir brauchen das Backpulver dafür [Musik]
so der Teig ist fertig mehl und Backpulver
braucht ihr wirklich nur so kurz wie notwendig
unterrühren ich habe jetzt hier meine eckige
Springform ich schreibe euch die Maße auch mit
in die Infobox und auch alternativ Maße bzw ich
habe ja eine Umrechnungstabelle bei mir auf der
Seite und da könnt ihr dann einfach ganz bequem
umrechnen ich brauche jetzt für meine Beschichtung
dadurch dass hier auch schon fett mit drin ist
kein Backpapier das heißt gebe ich es einfach
so mit rein Ofen habe ich vorgeheizt auf 170
Grad Ober und Unterhitze und dann ist wichtig
dass ihr das halt einmal noch schön glatt
verstreichen und dann wird gebacken [Musik]
25 Minuten später also wenn ihr die
Stäbchenprobe macht darf es darf
jetzt nicht komplett nass sein aber es darf
ruhig ein bisschen was dran hängen bleiben
soll ja so ein Brownie Charakter haben so
bei mir ist es vollständig abgekühlt ich
habe jetzt hier noch Puderzucker und da gebe ich
Zitronensaft drauf die einfachste Glasur der Welt
so erstmal noch ein bisschen und wenn ich merke
dass wir die Konsistenz gefällt dann gebe ich
das einfach noch mal oben drüber und lasse ich
das noch mal so ein bisschen aushärten und dann
könnt ihr direkt servieren ihr könnt das Ganze
übrigens drei Tage lang Essen ist so saftig und
es schmeckt auch am nächsten Tag noch gut und
somit könnt ihr das auch sehr gut vorbereiten
[Musik]
geht immer Leute also was soll ich sagen
alle lieben Zitronenkuchen alle lieben
Zitronen Brownies ich muss sagen wenn man den
jetzt vergleicht mit meinem Zitronenkuchen
Rezept da sind so ein paar Feinheiten die ein
bisschen anders sind das hier ist im Vergleich
ein bisschen klitschiger und das andere ist ein
bisschen luftiger je nachdem was ihr bevorzugt
könnt ihr euch dann ein Rezept aussuchen ich
feiere das übelst und ich finde es auch cool
dass ich dir jetzt hier so in kleinere
Häppchen aufgeteilt habe so könnt ihr
das dann zum Geburtstag mitnehmen beim Grillen
irgendwie als Snack ähm danach mega feier ich
macht's unbedingt nach und abonniert meinen
Kanal kostenlos wenn ihr solche Rezepte nicht
mehr verpassen möchtet und dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten Mal [Musik] tschüss [Musik]